Oh
[Silence]
I s
I Whatever
I
[Silence]
I'mma
love
you.
Oh,
[Silence]
heat.
Alhamdulillah.
forch.
[Silence]
forchech.
for
[Silence]
you, Muhammad. Wasam.
Quran.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us in a
verse of the Quran that the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam
would recite every night before going to
bed as part of a greater chapter.
Isra
is one of the
chapters of the Quran that tells us he
would not sleep without reciting before
he went to bed
every night. Why? Because surah is
essentially one of the chapters of the
Quran that captures the essence of the
Quran,
the essence of what Allah has commanded,
the essence of who the human being is,
the essence of the names and attributes
of Allah, the essence of the judgment of
Allah, all is captured in Isra.
And so every night the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam would recite this
chapter before he went to bed.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
that which translates to and we send
down
of the Quran that which is
an antidote, a medicine for what is in
the chests of men.
And it is a mercy for the believers
and it the Quran will only increase the
disbelievers and their failure.
Listen to the words of this verse.
We send down and continue to send
over time
verses of the Quran which are a
medicine, an antidote
for that which is in the chest of man.
What is in the chest? The heart.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in no
uncertain terms that true blindness is
not blindness of the eyes.
True blindness
is blindness of the heart which is in
the chest.
The heart.
This is
the place in the human body
which contains the essence of the human
being.
The heart in the chest
is the part of the human being
which
contains its deepest
its deepest which contains the human
being's deepest beliefs
deepest understandings
which is referred to in Arabic as
[Silence]
he says
true understanding the mind
it is found in the heart,
the mind, not the brain.
This is an organ that helps us to
capture the world around us.
But the essence of our soul, the essence
of our thought, the essence of our
beliefs, who we are
is found in the heart which is in the
chest.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us that
the Quran acts as a medicine and an
antidote for the heart.
And he tells us subhanahu wa ta'ala that
the Quran is only an increase of mercy
for the believers.
But those who turn away from it, those
who disbelieve in it, it will only
increase them
in their failure.
How is it that the Quran
could be an antidote for some
and an increase in the failure of others
simultaneously?
Well, that's because of how it is
received.
If a person receives the Quran with open
arms and an open heart,
then the Quran will act as a medicine
and an antidote.
It will truly correct his mind,
not necessarily his brain, his mind.
And if a person rejects the Quran,
scoffs at the Quran, thumbs his nose at
the Quran, ignores the Quran, acts like
it doesn't exist,
it doesn't mean the Quran goes away.
It will still be an intimate part of
every human being's life.
It's just that this Quran will no longer
act as a medicine
but it will act as an increase
in the failure of those who are destined
for such failure.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam
explains this concept
in the narration of annis. The prophet
sallall.aii wasallam says
Quran.
[Silence]
Jenn
Our
[Silence]
prophet Sam
explains this verse and others it
and the relationship shared
by the people and the book of Allah, the
Quran.
He says the Quran
to every human being
is either
an interceder
whose intercession is honored
or an opponent who is unbeatable
to every person, you, me, every single
one of us.
When we meet Allah, we will be judged
according to the Quran.
And so all of the excuses that human
beings give themselves,
the human being is very good at excuses.
The human being is very good at excuses,
very good at talking.
No matter how many excuses we make for
ourselves, the excuse of, "Well, at
least I'm not as bad as so and so. I'm
not that bad. I mean, there's worse out
there than me."
A person will not be judged based on
soand so. A person will not be compared
to the guy down the road. A person will
not be compared to the worst of them. A
person will be compared and weighed
based on the Quran. That is your
judgment. That is your yard stick. That
is the scales in which you and your
deeds will be found on the day of
judgment.
And so the Quran, it will either act as
an interceder on your behalf. and Allah
has already guaranteed the Quran's
intercession
or it will act as an unbeatable
unrivaled opponent in the court of Allah
the judge of judges subhanahu wa ta'ala
he further explains he says whoever puts
the Quran in front of him it will guide
him to paradise it will guide him to
paradise
And whoever puts the Quran
behind his back, it will drive him into
the depths of hell.
It will drive him to damnation.
Just because a person ignores the Quran,
acts it doesn't exist, doesn't make
it go away.
We are responsible for the Quran and its
reception.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has made
the Quran the source of many
a source of healing and guidance and
illumination for many
and he has also made the Quran an
unbeatable opponent for many others.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in surah
the chapter of the thunder and this
chapter of the Quran is an incredible
chapter because every part of it from
start to finish is an analogy
and an allegory for the Quran
every verse Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tells us in
He says
indeed
it is only by the remembrance of Allah
do the hearts find tranquility.
There is so much meaning behind this
sentence.
One of the meanings of this sentence is
that if a person does not find his
tranquility in the Quran, his heart is
dead.
his heart,
it needs to be revived.
If a person
flees from the Quran, if a person finds
the Quran to be uncomfortable,
this person has a disease in his heart.
Because anything that is worthy of being
named a heart of a human being, it finds
tranquility in the remembrance of Allah.
In the Quran,
we look around us today and we see so
much anxiety, so much depression,
etc., etc., And we're not speaking about
true mental illnesses
that are biological
issues.
There are illnesses which are biological
issues. They need a physical medicine.
It needs to be administered by a
professional.
But
all of this anxiety and depression and
confusion and emotional immaturity
and
most of this
is a byproduct of feeling lost.
Most of this is a byproduct and a result
of not knowing who you are, not knowing
why you are, and not knowing what the
future holds for you. And how could you
not be depressed and anxious if that is
your case?
How can a human being
does not know where he came from, who
his creator is, why he exists, where he
is going, and why things are the way
they are. How could this person not be
depressed?
How could he not drink himself silly?
How could he not take himself with drugs
and alcohol to the brink of death?
How how can a person remain
upstanding
without the book of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala?
And so when a person turns and looks for
guidance in the Quran,
his heart begins to be revived.
One of the great things of the Quran
is that it has in it both diagnosis
and remedy
because all healing is two two halves.
We need to diagnose and the second half
we need to treat. Both are found in the
Quran, the book of Allah.
When a person reads the Quran, not in an
abstract way, not you're reading a
novel or a magazine,
not in a way where you have preconceived
notions and presuppositions and now
you're merely looking to reinforce what
you think you already know in the Quran.
That's not going to help you. That's not
how a believer reads the Quran.
When you read the Quran, you read it
with the most open, vulnerable heart.
You read every verse and your heart and
your mind is calling out to Allah with
every verse, with every movement of your
lips and tongue. Oh Allah, I know
nothing, so teach me. Oh Allah, I am
nothing. So make something of me. And if
you read the Quran in that way,
you will begin to heal immediately
today.
Doesn't mean you'll be free of all
problems. No, that takes time.
Because the diseases of the heart are
the diseases of the body.
When you first try to treat the disease,
it starts to fight back. And sometimes
it gets worse before it gets better. It
reacts to the medicine. It tries to
fight for survival.
You become afraid. Whispers fill your
mind and chest. If I really take this
book seriously, it's going to change
everything. And I don't want my my life
to change. I'm comfortable just how I
am. Human beings, we are naturally
terrified of change.
It scares us to our core. We don't want
to change. Don't rock the boat. Just
leave everything exactly it is. But
you have to lose sight of the shore to
reach new places.
You have to lose sight of what makes you
comfortable in order to arrive at a
better place. That's part of it. And the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam he assures
you. He assures me he gave us a
guarantee. He said,
he says, "Whoever leaves something for
the sake of Allah, Allah will replace it
for him with something better." The
human being is always terrified.
Yeah. But if I leave off this thing, if
I leave this off or that off, if I
change my ways, it's going to be
uncomfortable
and I'm going to get anxiety and I'm
going to get depressed and I'm going to
get you have to let go.
You have to fall and trust Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
But the Quran will change you
immediately
and irreparably or we should say
irreversibly if it truly enters your
heart.
My brothers and my sisters, when we look
at the human being, how Allah takes us
naturally through the stages of life, we
fight and he takes us kicking and
screaming from one level to the next and
it always is better.
He gives us an example
in his book. He says, "Look at the human
being. When a person is in his mother's
womb, he is nourished by one
method, one path of nourishment, which
is the umbilical cord. That's it. You
get everything from that one. But when
it's time to move into the next stage of
life, the child doesn't want to come
out. The child is comfortable, cozy,
safe, everything's nice in there. I
don't want to come out. But when Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala brings the child out
and cuts off that path of sustenance,
which is the umbilical cord, he replaces
it with two paths of sustenance when he
suckles from his mother's milk.
And when he is weaned and the time comes
for him to no longer have those two
paths
of nourishment
and it is he is done suckling
he doesn't want to he wants to continue
to stay there but Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala cuts those those two paths off
and he replaces those two paths with
four types of nourishment.
meat and that which grows from the earth
and water and that which he drinks four
types of nourishment he says and when
the time comes for the human being to
die he doesn't want to die but when
Allah cuts off that path of sustenance
if he is a believer he gives him eight
paths of sustenance eight gates of
paradise to enter through which he
chooses.
Allah never cuts off something except
that he replaces it with that which is
better.
Yeah.
And so my brothers and my sisters, many
of us, we have access to the Quran. We
could read the Quran now.
But why don't we?
Why don't we really read the Quran?
Why don't we truly study the Quran?
Why is it not a bigger part of our
lives?
the truth
because we're afraid of the changes that
it will implement. We're afra we're
afraid of the imple we're we are afa
afraid of the implications
of the Quran because the Quran is not
any other book. It demands change
and it scares us. It scares us to look
in the Quran a kind of mirror and see
ourselves as we truly are. We want to
feel everything's okay. I don't
want to hear that I'm not good, that I
need to be better, that there's a long
hard road ahead of me.
But no good change will come without
strong will. And no one will truly find
guidance and stability
except in the book of Allah, the Quran.
You read it with an open heart,
with an open mind,
and you understand it as the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam taught us
as it has been passed down to us through
the centuries by way of our scholars.
And your life will change and change for
the better and it will continue to get
better and better until you meet Allah.
And this is why the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam tells us
[Silence]
He says that on the day of judgment, the
person of the Quran,
he will be said and told by Allah,
recite
as you used to recite in the dunya and
rise with every verse you recite
because your place and level in paradise
is at the final verse that you used to
recite. That final verse of the Quran
that you learned, that you read, that
you implemented,
that you put into action that gave you
life in the dunya. Your final place in
paradise is whatever final verse. For
this reason, al- Mundi, he says that the
scholars have mentioned because of this
narration that the levels of paradise
are at least the amount of verses in the
[Arabic recitation]
speech. Foreign speech. Foreign speech.
[Silence]
Allah.
Allham.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Allah
[Silence]
High.
Stand shoulder tosh shoulder.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
Holy
Allah. Oh my god.
Allah
Allah.
I can help.
Oh my god.
Allah.
Alhamdulillah.
Foreign
speech. Foreign speech. Foreign speech.
for
a
meanche.
[Silence]
for
Allah.
So Allah
Allah
won't let your bell
[Silence]
felt
Rahmed
Oh,
[Silence]
allayikum brothers and sisters. Couple
of quick announcements. First one is we
have a potluck tonight between Mr and
Isha. Please bring your favorite dish
and share it with your family and
friends here in Tucson. So you again
it's going to be between Mab and Isha
inshallah is potluck. So please bring
your favorite dish. also we have the
couple of more weeks left for the summer
program and allow your children to
benefit from that program inshallah. So
that will be that has been pretty
productive and and helpful to a lot
of kids. So please see if you can
benefit your children also from that
program
and donate generously on the way out. U
we are also still looking for some
teachers. If you have anybody anybody
who is interested in teaching at the
Rahama Academy, please bring that
information or bring the resume to the
to the office.
Donate generously on the way out.